caleb smith is on the mound for the
arizona diamondbacks tonight
he made a start april 3rd against san
diego then went into the bullpen he's
performed very well for the d-backs
there they pull him out of the bullpen
to make the start against the mets
tonight
maybe some of that reason is when he was
a miami marlin he used to pitch very
effectively against the mets we'll see
if he does so tonight jonathan vr
will lead things off eighth pitch of the
oath pinning it back and it's low ball
four in vr as he did last night walks to
lead off the game so here's lyndora's
got a couple of home runs and five
career at bats against caleb smith
popped up and backing out
is rojas his second baseman he makes the
catch for the out
that's the first out of the game and now
pete alonso will bat
vr at first got picked off for the first
out of the game last night
they are going on first move they got
him picked off that's a big help for
caleb right there
he got picked off for the ball game last
night first inning this could turn out
to be
a good inning for caleb if he can find a
way to retire the polar bear here
there's a
fly ball ahmed i can hear him up here in
the booth calling for it makes the catch
shot left center field to retire a
lounge zone in the inning
there's a good inning for caleb smith
marcus strowman takes the bound in the
bottom of the first it's time for a good
old-fashioned
stroke show in the desert 54
ground ball rate that's among the best
of the major leagues josh rojas leads
off against strowman hunched to the left
side vr the only man over there
and he makes the running toss in time to
get rojas for the first down as cattell
martay
rolls over one down the first easy play
for alonso
good sticker by strowman to get martay
for the second out there's escobar
eduardo has it safely now in 15 of his
last 16 games
broken bat this one might drop in there
and make it an eight game hit streak
that smile from eduardo here's david
peralta went over four last night
swinging a miss strike three split
change and a strut from strowman off the
mound
as he retires david peralta with his
first strike
out of the game inning is over dom smith
leads off of the mets in the second
this one to second smothered by rojas
nicely done
nice play there by josh state get away
from dominic smith
stephen vogt advances to second that'll
be a wild pitch
rbi chance for nick if he can come up
with two out knocks swinging a missed
strike three
stroman went to the high fastball it
doesn't go to the fourth seam
very often but sometimes he'll dial it
upstairs
and he does there to strike out nick
ahmed two up two set down here in the
third and can tell martay
will now step in ripped to center field
to base hit
it's on the no two pitch that goes all
the way to the wall two out double by
marty
well he's in scoring position for the
national league rbi leader
edwardo escobar let's hit hard but right
out of lonzo down the first base line he
takes it to the bag himself
this time and that will retire the
d-backs
in the third caleb smith will work to
the mets order for the second time
first time through he faced the minimum
just gave up a walk one out
it'll bring up francisco lindor that's a
fair ball at third long throw escobar
how about
pavon smith keeping a foot on the back
and they get lindor
long throw for eduardo and a tremendous
ballet down there on the other end by
payman smith
pete alonso now the battery hit hard and
into left field for a base hit
it seems to be working for pete a couple
of hits last night and he ripped that
one into left field
a two-out hit here in the fourth and dom
smith will now step to the plates dom
hits one deep to right center back
toward the wall it's out of here
dove smith's home run drought is over
138 at bats without a home run
and dom goes deep and the mitts lead it
two nothing well after we left you to go
to break
a little bit of a dust up as marcus
strowman and josh rojas started jawing
at each other after rojas made the final
out of the inning and both
dugouts empty marcus can get under
people's skin this is a diamondbacks
team that's lost 14 of their last 15
they're obviously very frustrated no
punches thrown just a lot of milling
about apparently much ado about nothing
no the mets have their lead off man on
now francisco lindor will be the batter
slammed in the air to center field by
lindor back goes marta
near the track and it's off the wall and
it bounces away from him
the yard of third he'll take the turn
there and be headed home
it's a triple for francisco indoor it
brings in a run and it's three-nothing
new york
so the mats after the little dust-up
between strowman and rojas come out
flying here in the sixth inning four
nothing new york the back-to-back base
hits against strowman
to start the bottom of the sixth now you
wondered how strowman would handle this
inning after clearly
getting emotionally involved in that
shouting match with josh rojas
he's got himself a four-nothing lead but
this is a ballpark that
can play very small and i will face
pavon smith who's been the hottest
hitter in this lineup
haven smith crushes one way back
goodbye wow and the diamondbacks are
suddenly back in this game
as the mitch lead has shrunk to four to
three
so it's a brand new ball game no man to
play back out there
after giving up two runs in the six
they'll start the seventh crown ball
back up the middle
diving play by rojas gets up throws and
they got him at first
what a play by rojas to throw out perez
for round number two
rojas who had the dust up with strowman
a couple of innings ago
makes a tremendous play and so a huge
spot here for familia trying to protect
a one-run lead in the seventh and air in
a walk would put two men aboard familia
is gonna stay in and face escobar one
two coming
struck him out familiar with the big
strikeout of escobar
to get the mets through the bottom of
the seventh edwin diaz
nine save opportunities no runs allowed
and he'll go for number 10 tonight a
single for ahmed and then an error on
mckinney
tying run in scoring position so now
with the tying run at third and two out
in the last of the ninth josh rojas
who had the dust up with marcus strowman
at the end of the fifth inning
base hit her tied josh rojas
who had some words with strowman gets to
shout
at the top of his lungs here now here's
marte
little flare trying to get down it drops
in rojas takes the turn
and falls over
oh josh rojas tripped over his own feet
coming around
second and just did get back safely
now the potential winning run is at
second base
escobar is two for four tonight struck
out in a big spot against familia and
the seventh gets another chance in the
ninth
and escobar flies one out to center
mason williams is there
and we're going to extra innings in the
desert james mccann
will be the pinch hitter for the mitch
inside out over the bag that's a fair
ball and that'll score peraza
it's 5-4 new york in the 10. and now the
tying and winning runs are on base
now face josh reddick with two on and
the line drive down the right field line
fair ball into the corner here comes
escobar
there comes pavon smith diamondbacks are
going to win the ball game
and the diamondbacks get the walk-off
win